you you were teaming up with with you  for Deadpool three yes yes I am very  excited about that  I mean that's that would be yeah that's  so fun yeah but Wolverine well he's  bringing he's Wolverine Wolverine yeah  we've figured out a way to do it that's  Hugh Jackman approved and Kevin feige  approved where we're completely  protecting the legacy of Logan the way  it was left off we wouldn't mess with  that  um and I'm I'm really excited about you  know as I've gotten a little bit older I  sort of want to I want to really I'm  lucky that I get to work in this  industry and particularly incredibly  fortunate I get to work in it this long  but I really want to work with people I  either are that are either immensely  talented or people that I love and that  are I'm genuinely like best friends with  and unfortunately Hugh does not qualify  as either of those but but I am but I am  excited because I'm A Logan fan so